As a species, something drives us to want to make inanimate things seem alive. There are statues where the whole idea seems to be to create a simulation of soft skin and sheer billowing cloth out of rock-- literally, out of a rock-- as if to prove this, too, can be human. There is just something about that moment when Pinocchio stops being a few strung together pieces of wood and starts to seem like he's really a little boy.
作为一个物种，我们内心有一种冲动，想要让无生命的事物看起来栩栩如生。有些雕像，其创作初衷似乎就是用岩石——真的是用岩石——创造出柔软皮肤和飘逸布料的模拟效果，仿佛在证明这也可以是人性的一部分。当匹诺曹不再只是几块绑在一起的木头，而开始看起来像个真正的小男孩时，那一刻总是让人感慨万千。
This week I caught a guy named Ronn Lucas, a ventriloquist who is best known for being able to make anything talk-- a banana, a box of breakfast cereal, a sock-- to ask him what he makes of all this. His dummies are named Buffalo Billy and Scorch.
本周我采访了罗恩·卢卡斯，他是一位口技表演者，最擅长让任何东西开口说话——香蕉、一盒麦片、一只袜子——我想问问他是如何看待这一点的。他的木偶名字叫“水牛比利”和“焦灼”。
When I'm on stage talking to my puppets, I believe they're real. I believe to the point, as an actor believes in his character.
当我在台上和木偶说话时，我相信它们是真实的。我相信这一点，就像演员相信自己的角色一样。
Charles Ludlam, of the Ridiculous Theater, had a dummy called Walter. And he wrote at one point about Walter, he sometimes says unexpected things. Does that happen with you, with Billy or Scorch?
“荒诞剧团”的查尔斯·勒德拉姆有一个叫沃尔特的木偶。他曾写道，沃尔特有时会说出一些意想不到的话。你和比利或焦灼之间发生过这种情况吗？
It has happened to me. There are a couple moments, too. I started to get through a breakthrough as a comedian. I was working a series of comedy clubs. And someone asked me if I would do a military club. And I said, yeah, sure, not knowing what I was getting into. I worked for the enlisted men. And they were just really into what I was doing.
我确实遇到过。有几次，也是我作为喜剧演员取得突破的时候。当时我在一系列喜剧俱乐部工作。有人问我是否愿意去一个军人俱乐部表演。我说，好啊，没问题，当时根本不知道自己要面对什么。我为服役士兵表演，他们非常喜欢我的演出。
But then I went over to the officer's club. And these guys were wild. I guess it's part of the responsibility of command, is that when you get to hang out just with other officers, you can let yourself go. But performing, I couldn't do my script. I couldn't do the show I had planned. So I just started doing question and answer stuff. Don Rickles, ethnic jokes, nothing that would really hurt anybody. But I was picking on everybody equally.
但后来我去了军官俱乐部。这些家伙简直太狂野了。我想这是指挥职责的一部分，当你只和军官们待在一起时，你可以彻底放松。但表演时，我无法照本宣科，无法按照预先计划的节目表演。所以我只是开始进行问答互动。唐·里克斯式的、关于民族的笑话，没伤害到任何人，但我对每个人都一视同仁地进行了调侃。
I had to preface that before I got to where I-- So one guy was an officer. And he was from Puerto Rico. I said hey, where are you from? And the guy said, Puerto Rico. And the dummy goes, how many Puerto Ricans does it take to screw in a light bulb? And I'm thinking to myself, why did I have him say that? I don't have an answer.
在我进入正题之前，我得先做个铺垫——当时有一个军官。他是波多黎各人。我说嘿，你从哪儿来？那家伙说，波多黎各。然后木偶就说，拧一个灯泡需要多少个波多黎各人？我心想，我为什么要让他说这个？我根本不知道答案。
Then, in a wink, the dummy came up with an answer. One funny enough to make an audience laugh in an officer's nightclub. But I have to say, not so funny that I want to alienate our lovely multicultural audience.
然后，在眨眼之间，木偶想出了一个答案。那个答案足够幽默，逗得军官夜总会的观众哈哈大笑。但我必须说，还没幽默到让我想要疏远我们可爱的多元文化观众的程度。
And why is it so pleasurable for something inanimate to suddenly become alive through a voice coming out of it?
为什么让无生命的东西通过发出的声音突然变得鲜活起来，会让人感到如此愉悦呢？
It is fascinating to hold a fork in your hand and wonder what it would say. I found myself doing that not too long ago around a table with some other ventriloquists.
手里拿着一把叉子，好奇它会说什么，这真是一件迷人的事。不久前，我和其他几位口技表演者围坐在一张桌子旁时，我发现自己也做了同样的事情。
And what did it say?
它说了什么？
And it said, your thumb is on my butt.
它说，你的大拇指放在我的屁股上了。
Right. Of course. Exactly.
对。当然。一点没错。
I treated it more like a person. I didn't think of it as a utility, or what it was going to do. I saw it as a human form. And my thumb was in the wrong place.
我把它当成了一个人。我没把它看作工具或它应该完成的任务，我把它看作一种人形。而我的大拇指放错位置了。
Which is exactly the point. Every object Ronn Lucas makes speak, he pretends is a person. This is exactly what we're doing as a species all the time. Turning things into people. And it begins when we're children, playing with dolls. That's true for men and women. Today on our program, what that's all about.
这正是重点所在。罗恩·卢卡斯让每个开口说话的物体，都假装是一个人。这正是我们作为一个物种一直在做的事情。把事物变成人。这始于我们童年玩洋娃娃的时候。无论是男人还是女人都是如此。今天，我们就来探讨这其中的奥秘。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, stories of dolls, dolls of all sorts, and what is it all about?
这里是芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台联合播出的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，关于玩偶的故事，各种各样的玩偶，这一切究竟是怎么回事？
Act One, Thank Heaven for Little Girls-- Made of Plastic. The story of a company that has figured out all the different ways that girls like dolls, and is trying to sell to nearly every single way they can think of. Act Two, You Know What Mr. Bear Would Say. The author of a once-famous series of children's books about a doll, and how her life came to resemble a doll's. Act Three, The Boy Who Would Be a Helicopter. Kindergarten teacher Vivian Paley tells the story of how, in this age when schools are eliminating the doll corner at younger and younger ages, it was playing with dolls that saved a kid in her class. Stay with us.
第一幕，感谢上帝创造了小女孩——还有塑料制品。一家公司摸清了女孩们喜欢玩偶的所有方式，并试图通过他们能想到的几乎每一种方式进行销售。第二幕，你知道熊先生会说什么。一位曾经著名的儿童书系列作家关于一个玩偶的故事，以及她的人生是如何变得像一个玩偶的。第三幕，想成为直升机的男孩。幼儿园老师薇薇安·佩利讲述了在一个学校越来越早地撤掉玩偶角的年代，玩耍玩偶是如何拯救了她班上的一个孩子。请继续收听。
Act One, Thank Heaven for Little Girls-- Made of Plastic. About a year ago, here in Chicago, just around the corner from all the fanciest stores that you can find for a three state radius-- Niketown, and the Sony Gallery, and Neiman Marcus, and all those kind-- a company began an experiment in marketing dolls to little girls. They opened a store, the only one that they have opened anywhere. This American Life producer Susan Burton headed down to American Girl Place.
第一幕，感谢上帝创造了小女孩——还有塑料制品。大约一年前，在芝加哥，就在方圆三个州内你能找到的所有最豪华商店的拐角处——耐克城、索尼画廊、尼曼百货，以及所有这类商店——一家公司开始了一项向小女孩营销玩偶的实验。他们开了一家店，这是他们在任何地方开的唯一一家店。《美国生活》制作人苏珊·伯顿前往了“美国女孩广场”。
It's American Girl Place, not American Girl store. The word place was what thrilled me before I had ever set foot inside. It seemed to connote a project of such grand scale. Build a monument on the Magnificent Mile, and they will come.
是“美国女孩广场”，而不是“美国女孩商店”。在我踏入大门之前，“广场”这个词就让我感到激动。它似乎暗示了一个宏大的项目。在“璀璨大道”上建立一座丰碑，他们就会蜂拥而至。
You see them on Saturday afternoons downtown, swarms of little girls. What you notice first is their shopping bags, which are bright, Crayola marker red with American Girl Place stamped in white across the side. Austere, grown-up looking bags. Even if the bags are large, banging against their legs, the girls tend to carry them by themselves.
周六下午在市中心，你会看到成群结队的小女孩。你首先注意到的是她们的购物袋，那是明亮的蜡笔红，侧面印着白色的“美国女孩广场”字样。严肃而成熟的包。即使袋子很大，撞击着她们的腿，女孩们也倾向于自己拎着。
In good coats and tights and Mary Janes, they look like little girls pretending to be little girls. The question of what to wear to American Girl Place has clearly been given careful consideration. Some girls are dressed like their dolls.
穿着好看的外套、连裤袜和玛丽珍鞋，她们看起来就像是在假装成为小女孩的小女孩。对于在美国女孩广场该穿什么，她们显然经过了仔细考虑。有些女孩的打扮和她们的玩偶一样。
I have the purple 2000 millennium outfit. There are purple tights that  are sparkly and a purple skirt that goes down to about my knees. I have a purple tank top with a purple cardigan.
我有紫色的2000年千禧装。有闪闪发光的紫色连裤袜和一条到我膝盖左右的紫色裙子。我有一件紫色吊带背心，配一件紫色开衫。
Whitney Robertson is 11 years old and came here from Saint Louis with her mother, Laura. She has short blond hair, braces. She moves with a heightened formality. It's as if she is wearing something magical and doesn't dare disturb the spell.
惠特尼·罗伯逊今年11岁，和她的母亲劳拉从圣路易斯来到这里。她留着金色短发，戴着牙套。她的动作带着一种高度的正式感。就好像她穿着某种神奇的东西，不敢破坏这咒语。
The most interesting thing is when she got her braces this year at Christmas time, she had to have purple-- what do you call them, spacers?
最有趣的是，今年圣诞节她戴上牙套时，她必须戴上紫色的——那叫什么来着，分牙器？
The purple rubber bands. Because I got my braces a few days after Christmas, so I knew I got the 2000 outfit. So that's the only reason I got purple. Otherwise would have gotten my favorite color, blue.
紫色的橡皮筋。因为我在圣诞节后几天戴的牙套，所以我知道我能拿到2000年的套装。这就是我选择紫色的唯一原因。否则我会选我最喜欢的蓝色。
So she was totally American Girl.
所以她完全是一个“美国女孩”。
Whitney and her mother have come to American Girl Place, not to Chicago, in the same way that you go to Disney World, rather than to Orlando. This is Whitney's first time here. Her parents gave her the trip for Christmas.
惠特尼和她的母亲来到美国女孩广场，并不是为了来芝加哥，就像你去迪士尼乐园，而不是为了去奥兰多。这是惠特尼第一次来这里。她的父母把这次旅行作为圣诞礼物送给了她。
There was a series of presents. The first one was a necklace that said, northern expressions. And I really didn't get it at the time, but it was a clue there we go north from Saint Louis. And then the next one was something from AG. I think it was a necklace.
这是一系列礼物。第一个是一个写着“北方表达”的项链。我当时真的没明白，但这显然是一个暗示，我们要从圣路易斯向北走。然后下一个是AG的礼物。我想是一条项链。
AG. American Girl.
AG。美国女孩。
And then the next one was airline tickets to the AG Place.
然后下一个是去AG广场的机票。
Whitney had this questioning look on her face, like, what? And then it dawned on her. And she just went, oh my gosh, and started to cry.
惠特尼脸上露出疑惑的表情，好像在说，什么？然后她恍然大悟。她只是说，哦，天哪，然后开始哭了起来。
True.
真的。
In the store's first year, about 40% of it's million visitors have come from out of town. This is retail as theme park. Destination shopping. There is a concierge desk, coat checks on both the first and third floors. There is a cafe, and a clothing department, a museum, and a live musical, loads of furniture and accessories, shelves of souvenirs, and, of course, the dolls themselves, which cost $82 each.
在商店开业的第一年，一百万游客中约有40%来自外地。这简直是零售业的主题公园。目的地购物。有一个礼宾台，一楼和三楼有衣帽间。有一家咖啡馆，一个服装部，一个博物馆，还有现场音乐剧，大量的家具和配饰，成排的纪念品，当然，还有玩偶本身，每个售价82美元。
A former school teacher with a storybook name, Pleasant Rowland, thought up the American Girl dolls about 15 years ago. There are six historic dolls. Each represents a different era, and is accompanied by a series of chapter books about her life and times.
一位有着故事书般名字的前学校老师，普莱森特·罗兰，大约15年前想出了“美国女孩”玩偶的创意。有六个历史玩偶。每一个代表一个不同的时代，并配有一系列关于她生活和时代的系列章节书。
Samantha, the most popular doll, is a Victorian girl. Molly misses her father, who is fighting in World War II. Addie escaped slavery and moved north to Philadelphia. The girls are spunky and independent, and the books are full of historical detail. Quiting bees, suffragettes, victory gardens.
最受欢迎的玩偶萨曼莎是一个维多利亚时代的女孩。莫莉想念正在二战中作战的父亲。艾迪逃离了奴隶制，向北移居到费城。女孩们坚强且独立，书中充满了历史细节。缝纫聚会、妇女参政论者、胜利花园。
About 5 million dolls have been sold since 1986, mostly by catalog. The company won't say to whom, but as a fourth grade teacher, Whitney's mother has noticed which girls tend to own the dolls.
自1986年以来，已经售出了约500万个玩偶，主要通过目录销售。公司不愿透露客户是谁，但作为一名四年级教师，惠特尼的母亲注意到了哪些女孩倾向于拥有这些玩偶。
I teach in a poorer area outside of Saint Louis. Most of the people would be lower middle class. I would say about 5% of my 9 to 10-year-olds right now. Now, my daughter's school, who is in the more middle class, maybe upper middle class, area, probably a good 80%--
我在圣路易斯郊区的一个贫困地区教书。大多数人属于中下阶层。我可以说目前我班上9到10岁的孩子里大约有5%拥有。而在我女儿的学校，那个处于中产阶级，或许是中上阶层地区的学校，可能有80%——
80%. Out of the whole school.
80%。整个学校。
Out of the whole school. Yes. Because you'll see them wearing the t-shirts. You'll see them carrying the dolls. And they talk about it a lot. And it's a big thing.
整个学校。是的。因为你会看到她们穿着T恤。你会看到她们带着玩偶。她们经常谈论这个。这是一件大事。
The crowd in the store seems well off. Mostly, but not entirely, white. One girl, who must be all of seven, with elegant upswept hair and a long burgundy coat, carries her wire shopping basket around all day with the authority of a duty free heiress.
店里的人群看起来都很富裕。主要是白人，但并非全是。一个看起来顶多七岁、留着优雅盘发并穿着长款酒红色外套的女孩，整天拎着她的铁丝购物篮，散发着免税店女继承人的权威感。
Whitney didn't even like dolls, her mother tells me, until she got the first Samantha book three years ago. The history drew Whitney into the doll. And lots of other girls I talked to do seem to genuinely like, and learn from, the books. But mostly, the girls play with these dolls the way they play with any dolls. They insert them into various domestic dramas. New school. Orphan. The universally popular "my girl's coming over to your girl's house."
惠特尼的母亲告诉我，惠特尼甚至不喜欢玩偶，直到三年前她得到第一本萨曼莎的书。历史吸引惠特尼喜欢上了这个玩偶。我和许多其他女孩聊过，她们确实似乎真心喜欢并从书中学习。但大多数情况下，女孩们玩这些玩偶的方式和玩任何玩偶一样。她们把玩偶放入各种家庭剧的情境中。新学校、孤儿，还有那个普遍流行的“我的玩偶去你玩偶家做客”。
And they do their hair. I hear that the problem with Molly is that her pigtails always fall out, that most girls prefer to undo Kirsten's braids.
她们还会给玩偶梳头。我听说莫莉的问题是她的辫子总是会散掉，大多数女孩更喜欢解开克里斯汀的辫子。
You get a little piece of the hair, and you brush it from the underside with a certain kind of brush for five minutes. And then it turns out more shiny than it was, and it won't be as frizzy.
你取一小撮头发，用一种特定的刷子从下往上刷五分钟。然后头发会比原来更有光泽，也不会那么毛躁了。
The ingenious thing about American Girl Place is not only that they seem to understand what a girl wants to do when she plays with her doll, but that they know how to participate in the game with her. It's as if the marketers have stepped into the center of a girl's dream and are selling to her from a perch in her own unconscious. The doll hair care products in this store rival a beauty salon's offerings. Employees roam the floor, dispensing styling tips.
美国女孩广场的天才之处不仅在于他们似乎了解女孩玩玩偶时想做什么，还在于他们知道如何参与到她的游戏中。就好像营销人员走进了女孩梦境的中心，从她潜意识的制高点向她兜售产品。店里的玩偶美发产品可以媲美美容院的供应。员工在卖场内走动，提供造型技巧。
Frizzy.
毛躁。
The lady was showing them down there how to brush their hair, and how they could put it up into little curlers.
那位女士在那边演示如何梳理头发，以及如何用小卷发棒把头发卷起来。
Again, Whitney's mother, Laura.
惠特尼的母亲劳拉再次说道。
And put water on it, and it would be shinier and it would be curly. I mean, they were taking the time to do this down there. Unbelievable.
然后用水喷一下，头发就会更有光泽、更有卷度。我是说，她们真的花时间在做这些。不可思议。
American Girl Place knows what girls want. And these days, this includes a look-alike doll. The American Girls of Today are available in 20 different skin, hair, and eye color combinations. Almost every single girl I talked to with a Today doll says she picked the one she did because it looked like her. And the Today accessories are varied enough to allow any girl to pursue her particular obsession.
美国女孩广场知道女孩想要什么。如今，这包括一个长得像自己的玩偶。今天的“美国女孩”有20种不同的肤色、发色和眼睛颜色组合。我聊过的几乎每一个拥有“当代女孩”玩偶的女孩都说，她选择这个是因为它看起来像她自己。而且“当代”配饰种类繁多，足以让任何女孩追求她特别的痴迷。
I'm pretty set, because I knew I wanted the wheelchair and the cast. I've been wanting one for about a year.
我基本定好了，因为我知道我想要轮椅和石膏。我想要这个已经有一年了。
True. We're not sure why. The medical thing. I don't know.
真的。我们不知道为什么。医疗题材的东西。我不清楚。
--husky right there.
——就在那儿，那个胖乎乎的。
That's Carrie. She's eight. She and her sister got the wheelchair yesterday. They've come back for the Apres-Ski set, which includes a tic-tac-toe board, a tiny thermos, and, most important, a bright yellow cast. They also want the dog sled, for accidents. They were in the midst of a complicated disaster narrative. A sort of Wild America meets Little House docudrama, which they began during their car trip to Chicago. Carrie needs the cast for a related story.
那是凯莉。她八岁。她和她姐姐昨天拿到了轮椅。她们回来是为了买滑雪后套装，里面有一块井字棋盘、一个小保温瓶，最重要的是，一个鲜黄色的石膏。她们还想要狗拉雪橇，以防发生事故。她们正处于一个复杂的灾难叙事中。一种“狂野美国”遇上“草原小屋”的纪录片风格故事，这是她们在来芝加哥的车程中开始的。凯莉需要石膏来对应相关的故事情节。
Because we're playing a game. And they're going on a camping trip. Horseback riding. And on the way back, she falls and gets stomped on the leg.
因为我们在玩一个游戏。她们要去露营。骑马。在回来的路上，她摔倒了，腿被踩伤了。
Then there are the collectors, the mint in boxers. By making the dolls collectible, American Girl Place can keep girls buying dolls long past the age they normally would. Their families can be a little spooky. I meet one grandmother who pulls from her handbag photographs of her granddaughter's closet. Yes, photos of a closet, filled with American Girl accessories. The stepgrandmother, who is also in the store, tells me that the girl has everything for Kirsten.
此外还有收藏家，那些玩偶还在包装盒里的收藏家。通过让玩偶具有收藏价值，美国女孩广场可以让女孩在过了正常年龄后继续购买玩偶。她们的家庭可能有点古怪。我见到了一位祖母，她从手提包里拿出她孙女衣橱的照片。是的，衣橱的照片，塞满了美国女孩的配饰。那个同样在店里的继祖母告诉我，那个女孩拥有克里斯汀的一切。
For a while there, she thought that this was too babyish for her, so got out of it. But then I think she has realized that this is something that you collect, and you can just enjoy your whole life, really. I was telling her about Demi Moore, that she has a collection of dolls, and she has a special house for all her dolls. So it's just a nice hobby.
有一段时间，她觉得这对她来说太幼稚了，所以不玩了。但我认为她意识到这是一个可以收藏的东西，你可以终身享受它。我告诉她黛米·摩尔的事，说她收藏玩偶，还有一间专门放她所有玩偶的房子。所以这只是一个很好的爱好。
Downstairs on the first floor, Whitney and her mother look at the dioramas. There are glassed-in living rooms filled with period furniture, one for each historic character, and display cases of accessories and clothing.
在楼下的一楼，惠特尼和她的母亲看着立体模型。有带玻璃的客厅，里面摆满了年代家具，每个历史角色一个，还有展示配饰和服装的陈列柜。
Samantha's bathing outfit. How would you like to be over at Lake Carlyle in the summer, when it's 104, and have to wear something like that?
萨曼莎的泳装。如果是在夏天，气温华氏104度的时候，你会想在卡莱尔湖穿着那样的衣服吗？
I mean, it's basically a dress.
我是说，那基本就是一件裙子。
Girls move past the dioramas in chronological order, as if in a museum. But not in a desultory field trip shuffle. They love this stuff. A girl dressed as Samantha lingers before Samantha's showcase, posing for pictures, staring at the doll's nightstand and her tiny copy of The Wizard of Oz. These items are called realia, which is the perfect word to describe what's so compelling about American Girl. Everything you buy makes the world of the doll more real. It makes her more real, which is what a lot of girls wish about their dolls.
女孩们按时间顺序经过这些立体模型，仿佛在博物馆里。但不是那种漫不经心的实地考察。她们热爱这些东西。一个打扮成萨曼莎的女孩在萨曼莎的展示柜前徘徊，摆姿势拍照，盯着玩偶的床头柜和她那本迷你的《绿野仙踪》。这些物品被称为“实物”，这是描述美国女孩为何如此吸引人的完美词汇。你买的每一样东西都让玩偶的世界变得更真实。这让玩偶变得更真实，而这正是许多女孩对她们玩偶的愿望。
And now, our last contestant, Miss Samantha Parkington.
现在，请出我们的最后一位参赛者，萨曼莎·帕金顿小姐。
In the musical review-- the theater is just past the dioramas-- the dolls are literally brought to life, channeled through six rosy-cheeked, middle school-age girls who act out stories the audience already knows from the American Girl books.
在音乐剧评论中——剧院就在立体模型旁边——玩偶们被赋予了生命，通过六个红润脸蛋、初中年纪的女孩来演绎，她们表演的都是观众从美国女孩书中早已熟知的故事情节。
After the musical, I have tea with Whitney and her mother. The cafe is elegant, in a cartoonish way. Dark pink carpet, lamps studded with plastic Gerbera daisies, overstuffed striped chairs. There is a harpist playing a Backstreet Boys song. Scones and tea sandwiches are served on tiered platters. Girls sip from iced pink lemonade. They sit up straight. They're giggly and polite.
音乐剧结束后，我和惠特尼还有她妈妈喝了茶。咖啡馆非常优雅，带有一种卡通感。深粉色的地毯，点缀着塑料非洲菊的灯具，填充感十足的条纹椅子。有一个竖琴手在演奏后街男孩的歌曲。司康饼和茶点三明治装在分层盘子里。女孩们抿着冰镇粉红柠檬水。她们坐得很直。她们爱笑而有礼貌。
There is a way in which the whole American Girl Place experience seems orchestrated around this moment, that hour when a girl plays out her own story book scene, steps into the illustration. Whitney evaluates the menu. Then she says this.
在某种程度上，整个美国女孩广场的体验似乎都是围绕这一刻设计的，那个女孩演绎自己故事书场景、走进插图的一小时。惠特尼评估着菜单。然后她说了这样一句话。
In the theater and in the American Girl Place, the employees make the dolls feel like they're real, and make you feel like they're real. And it's really, really neat.
在剧院和在美国女孩广场，员工让玩偶感觉像是真的，让你也觉得它们是真的。这真的、真的很棒。
What do they do that makes the dolls feel real?
她们做了什么让玩偶感觉是真的？
In the tea and the lunch, in the cafe room, they get a chair for the doll, and if she has a dress on, fix the dress and set her in it, and then put her on the table.
在茶会和午餐时，在咖啡厅，她们会给玩偶拿一把椅子，如果玩偶穿着裙子，就整理好裙子让它坐下，然后把它放在桌子上。
Almost everyone in the room clips one of these miniature chairs to her table. The girl at the table next to us neatly hangs Molly's winter coat over the back. And even though the chairs are for sale outside for $25, there's something lovely about seeing everyone engaged in the same game of pretend together.
房间里几乎每个人都把这些迷你椅子扣在她们的桌子上。我们隔壁桌的女孩整齐地把莫莉的冬装大衣挂在椅背上。即使这些椅子在外面以25美元的价格出售，看到每个人都沉浸在共同的假装游戏中，还是有一种美妙的感觉。
Whitney is on the upper end of the American Girl demographic. She says that in sixth grade, a lot of kids think that dolls are babyish, that she doesn't take her around too many places. And as she gives Samantha a sip from a tiny teacup, slips the napkin holder-- that also serves as a scrunchy-- into her hair, it's clear that one of the things she likes so much about the store is that it's a public space for playing dolls, maybe the only such place anywhere.
惠特尼处于美国女孩受众群体的最高端。她说在六年级，很多孩子认为玩偶很幼稚，她不会带着玩偶去太多地方。当她让萨曼莎抿了一口迷你茶杯，将餐巾扣——同时也用作发圈——戴在头发上时，很明显，她如此喜欢这家店的原因之一就是，这里是一个公开的玩偶游乐空间，也许是任何地方唯一这样的空间。
It's almost 5 o'clock when we finish tea. And Whitney has to make her last purchases. She heads to the American Girl of Today room, which is the only place in the store where you see packs of seven-year-old girls shopping without their mothers. The atmosphere is that of a slumber party gone awry. The walls are painted black. It feels like a night club for little girls.
喝完茶快5点了。惠特尼必须进行最后的采购。她前往“今日美国女孩”房间，这是店里唯一一个你能看到一群七岁女孩在没有母亲陪同下购物的地方。气氛就像一场搞砸了的睡衣派对。墙壁被涂成黑色。感觉就像一个小女孩的夜总会。
Whitney wants to get a fleece jacket for her doll, one that looks exactly like a fleece jacket from the Gap would if you threw it in the dryer for a month.
惠特尼想给她的玩偶买一件抓绒外套，看起来就像你在干衣机里烘干了一个月的Gap抓绒外套一样。
You sure that's absolutely what you want?
你确定那是你绝对想要的吗？
Yep.
是的。
But it's not a theme outfit. I thought you wanted another theme outfit.
但这不是主题套装。我以为你想要另一套主题套装。
I do. But I really want this one.
我是想。但我真的很想要这一件。
I would rather buy you a theme outfit.
我宁愿给你买一套主题套装。
OK. Let's go get a theme outfit.
好吧。我们去买一套主题套装。
A theme outfit means an historical outfit. Whitney's mother is pushing for the educational experience. We take the escalators down two floors to the turn of the century Samantha clothing. Whitney points at a striped dress with a pinafore.
主题套装意味着一套历史服装。惠特尼的母亲在推动教育体验。我们乘自动扶梯下到两层，来到世纪之交的萨曼莎服装区。惠特尼指着一件带有围裙的条纹裙子。
That's the birthday outfit. The pink-striped dress with the little pinafore thingy over it. I like that one.
那是生日套装。粉色条纹裙，外面有那个小围裙东西。我喜欢那件。
$22.
22美元。
But I also like the plaid cape and gaiters.
但我也喜欢格子斗篷和护腿。
I thought you liked the blue dress in the back?
我还以为你喜欢后面那件蓝色的裙子呢？
I do. But I like the regular clothes up there better.
我是喜欢。但我更喜欢上面的那些常规衣服。
We head back up to the American Girl of Today room. Girls pulling out boxes, trying on slippers, crowding the aisles in a final shopping frenzy. This is the only thing in the store that's not a game of make believe believe. Buying.
我们回到“今日美国女孩”房间。女孩们拿出盒子，试穿拖鞋，挤在过道里进行最后的购物狂欢。这是店里唯一不是假装游戏的东西。购买。
What's the decision?
决定是什么？
I want the regular clothes, the AG of Today.
我想要那些常规服装，“今日AG”。
Whitney shows us her final pick. It's an outfit the girls wore in the musical's finale, white overalls emblazoned with a silver star. She also has a doll-sized American Girl Place t-shirt and a snow dome that trills a song from the musical.
惠特尼展示了她最后的选择。那是女孩们在音乐剧结尾穿的衣服，绣着银星的白色背带裤。她还有一个玩偶大小的“美国女孩广场”T恤和一个摇晃后会演奏音乐剧中歌曲的雪景球。
These accessories aren't about history, or anything other than the experience of coming to the store. The brand itself. One thing Whitney likes about the outfit she has bought for her doll, she tells me, is that it comes with a miniature red shopping bag stamped with the words American Girl Place. The cashier puts Whitney's items into a bright red sack of her own. And she and her mother head out to Michigan Avenue.
这些配饰与历史无关，除了来到店里的体验之外什么都没有。品牌本身。惠特尼喜欢她为玩偶买的这套衣服的一点，她告诉我，是因为它带有一个印着“美国女孩广场”字样的迷你红色购物袋。收银员把惠特尼的商品装进她自己明亮的红色袋子里。她和她母亲向密歇根大道走去。
Susan Burton.
苏珊·伯顿。
[MUSIC - "AMERICAN GIRL," TOM PETTY AND THE HEARTBREAKERS]
[音乐 - “美国女孩”，汤姆·佩蒂与伤心人乐队]
Act Two, You Know What Mr. Bear Would Say. There is a children's book that just came back in print that is truly one of the most remarkable books I have ever seen, the kind of book that all this week, whenever anybody from our staff mentioned the book to somebody who happened to have read it as a child, there was actually this bonding moment. That's the only way to describe it. There would be a bonding moment, and then excited stories about what the book meant to them as a kid.
第二幕，你知道熊先生会说什么。有一本刚重新出版的儿童书，确实是我见过的最了不起的书之一。这种书本周我们员工中无论谁提到它，只要对方小时候读过，真的会产生一种连结时刻。这是描述它的唯一方式。会有一个连结时刻，然后是关于这本书在童年对他们意味着什么的兴奋故事。
Jean Nathan tells the story of the book and its author, and how the author's life came to resemble something from her book.
简·内森讲述了这本书和它作者的故事，以及作者的生活是如何变得像她书中的东西。
It was in the spring of 1997 that the artist's image floated into my mind, the cover of a children's book I hadn't seen, or even thought of, in more than 30 years. There it lodged, and there it remained. It felt as if it were a message, and its insistence startled me. After all, I live among the grown-ups now.
1997年春天，艺术家的形象浮现在我的脑海中，我三十多年没见过、甚至没想过的一本儿童书的封面。它就在那里扎了根，并一直留在那里。感觉就像一个信息，它的坚持让我吃惊。毕竟，我现在生活在成年人中间。
But the image just kept flashing in my mind. Pink and white gingham inset with a black and white photograph of Edith, the lonely doll, an open book between her spread, outstretched legs.
但这个图像一直在我的脑海中闪现。粉红色和白色格纹背景，镶嵌着一张黑白照片，照片是孤独的玩偶伊迪丝，在她张开的双腿之间摊开一本书。
My own copy of The Lonely Doll was long lost. And I soon learned from a bookstore clerk, who gave me the name of the author, Dare Wright, that the book was out of print. The New York Public Library's computer listed three copies, all damaged or missing. When I called a children's book searcher listed in the phone book, she said she knew the book well, and would add my name to her waiting list.
我自己那本《孤独的玩偶》早已丢失。我很快从书店职员那里得知了作者戴尔·赖特的名字，书已经绝版了。纽约公共图书馆的电脑里有三本，但都有损坏或缺失。当我给电话簿里列出的一位儿童书搜索员打电话时，她说她很了解这本书，并会把我的名字加到她的等候名单上。
Meaning to close the phone book, I found myself turning distractedly to the listings for the name Wright. And there, jumping out at me from blurred columns of typeface, was Wright, Dare. 11 East 80th Street, 249-6965. I don't think I could have been any more amazed if the address given had been, say, second to the right, and then straight on till morning, Peter Pan's address on the island of Neverland.
正打算合上电话簿时，我不经意地翻到了姓“赖特”的列表。就在那里，从模糊的字体列中跳出来的是，赖特，戴尔。东80街11号，249-6965。我想，如果地址是，比如说，向右转再直走直到清晨，彼得·潘在梦幻岛的地址，我也不可能更惊讶了。
In the weeks to come, I dialed the number several times. There was never an answer. I also sent a letter expressing how much the book had meant to me as a child, and asking if she knew where I could find a copy. Several months later, I finally received The Lonely Doll from the book searcher.
在接下来的几周里，我拨了几次这个号码。从来没人接。我还写了一封信，表达了这本书在小时候对我的意义，并询问她是否知道我在哪里能找到一本。几个月后，我终于从图书搜索员那里收到了《孤独的玩偶》。
Illustrated with black and white photographs, The Lonely Doll is the story of a doll named Edith, mired in loneliness, seemingly parentless, eating her cereal alone, going to bed alone, begging some pigeons on the windowsill to be her friends, and watching as they just fly away. One morning, two teddy bears, Mr. Bear and Little Bear, appear in her garden. They tell her they've come to be her friends. They move right in.
《孤独的玩偶》用黑白照片插图，讲述了一个名叫伊迪丝的玩偶的故事，她深陷孤独，似乎没有父母，独自吃麦片，独自上床睡觉，恳求窗台上的鸽子做她的朋友，看着它们飞走。一天早上，两只泰迪熊，熊先生和小熊，出现在她的花园里。它们告诉她它们是来做她朋友的。它们直接搬了进去。
Home alone, one rainy day, Edith and Little Bear discover, behind a set of louvered doors, a grown-up woman's closet and dressing room. The identity of the woman, and her absence, are never explained. She might be Edith's mother, but from all indications Edith has no mother.
一个雨天，独自在家的伊迪丝和小熊发现，在百叶门后面，有一个成年女性的衣橱和更衣室。这个女人的身份和她的缺席从未得到解释。她可能是伊迪丝的母亲，但所有迹象表明伊迪丝没有母亲。
A frenzied dress-up session follows, in which Edith and Little Bear adorn themselves with rhinestones and pearls, a petticoat, and a hat with roses and ribbons, high-heeled shoes, a leopard handbag. In their recklessness, they knock over a vase with one long-stemmed rose. The water spills into a jewelry box, but they are oblivious.
随之而来的是疯狂的换装，伊迪丝和小熊用莱茵石和珍珠、衬裙、带玫瑰和丝带的帽子、高跟鞋、豹纹手袋装饰自己。在鲁莽中，它们打翻了一个插着长茎玫瑰的花瓶。水溅进了首饰盒，但它们全然不知。
Wielding a fully swiveled out lipstick, Little Bear goads Edith to put it on. She says she wouldn't dare. You know what Mr. Bear would say. Then, just as Little Bear uses the lipstick to scrawl "Mr. Bear is just a silly old thing" across the oval mirror, who should appear but Mr. Bear.
小熊拿着一支完全拧出来的口红，怂恿伊迪丝涂上。她说她不敢。你知道熊先生会怎么说。然后，就在小熊用口红在椭圆形的镜子上乱画“熊先生只是个傻老头”时，熊先生出现了。
Spankings ensue, but the deeper issue striking terror in Edith is that her disobedience could jeopardize the whole arrangement, and that Edith would be, once again, abandoned and lonely. Yet when the little ones clean up the mess and promise never to do it again, Mr. Bear solemnly promises that he and Little Bear will stay with her forever and ever.
随之而来的是责打，但让伊迪丝感到恐惧的深层问题是，她的不服从可能会危及整个安排，伊迪丝会再次被遗弃和孤独。然而，当小家伙们清理干净烂摊子并承诺永不再犯时，熊先生庄严地保证他和熊弟弟会永远永远和她在一起。
About the time the book arrived, I received a phone call from a woman named Brooke Ashley. She said my letter had been forwarded to her in California. She said she was Dare's unofficial goddaughter and legal guardian, and that Dare, now 84, was in a hospital on life support. She said she was coming to New York to begin closing up Dare's apartment. Did I want to meet her at 11 East 80th Street?
书到手的那段时间，我接到了一个名叫布鲁克·阿什利的女性的电话。她说我的信被转寄给了她在加州的地址。她说她是戴尔的非官方教女和法定监护人，戴尔现在84岁，在医院依靠生命维持系统。她说她要来纽约开始清理戴尔的公寓。我愿意在东80街11号见她吗？
When I arrived at the apartment, Brooke met me at the door and led me to the living room. I was spellbound. The living room was filled with portraits, some life-sized, of a beautiful blond woman. That's Dare, Brooke said. They were all painted by her mother. Dare, I was shocked to realize, looked very much like Edith, the lonely doll. And Edith, I learned, was named for Dare's mother.
当我到达公寓时，布鲁克在门口迎接我，带我去了客厅。我被迷住了。客厅里挂满了画像，有些是真人大小，是一个美丽的金色头发女人。那是戴尔，布鲁克说。它们都是她母亲画的。我震惊地意识到，戴尔看起来非常像伊迪丝，那个孤独的玩偶。而伊迪丝，我得知，是以戴尔的母亲命名的。
As I left, Brooke gave me Dare's fat, leather-bound scrapbook, containing the record of her publishing career, including jacket covers, reviews, and other articles relating to the first 12 of her 19 books for children. The Lonely Doll was her first book. I had never known of the rest.
我离开时，布鲁克给了我戴尔厚厚的皮面剪贴簿，记录了她的出版生涯，包括书封、评论和其他与她19本童书中的前12本有关的文章。《孤独的玩偶》是她的第一本书。我从不知道其余的。
The Lonely Doll received mountains of publicity when it was first published in 1957. It was serialized in Good Housekeeping. It climbed the children's best seller list in the New York Times. It was translated into 6 foreign languages, and remained in print, in various formats, for 35 years.
《孤独的玩偶》在1957年首次出版时获得了大量的宣传。它在《好管家》杂志上连载。它登上了《纽约时报》儿童畅销书排行榜。它被翻译成6种外语，并以各种形式保持了35年的印刷。
I sorted through the piles of clippings and photographs I had been given by Brooke. Mostly, they were photographs of Dare. There were magnificent photos of Dare playing dress-up in elaborate costumes. But the most startling ones depicted Dare across a spectrum of ages in what could be described as undress, or partially so. These photos were just as posed as those of her in costume.
我整理了布鲁克给我的剪报和照片堆。大部分是戴尔的照片。有戴尔穿着精致服装玩换装的华丽照片。但最令人吃惊的照片描绘了戴尔在不同年龄段处于可被描述为没穿衣服或部分没穿衣服的状态。这些照片和她穿服装的照片一样都是摆拍的。
Dare, as I just began to discover, had lived in her own version of a wonderland. I spent the next two years talking to anyone I could find who knew her, trying to make sense of the world I had stumbled into.
正如我刚开始发现的那样，戴尔生活在属于她自己的仙境版本中。在接下来的两年里，我与任何我能找到认识她的人交谈，试图弄清楚我偶然闯入的世界。
In 1917, when Dare was three, her parents divorced. Her father was given custody of Dare's five-year-old brother, Blaine. Her parents seem to have made a pact that the brother and sister should never see each other again.
1917年，当戴尔三岁时，她的父母离婚了。她的父亲获得了戴尔五岁哥哥布莱恩的监护权。她的父母似乎达成了一个约定，兄妹俩永远不要再见。
Dare and her mother moved to Cleveland, Ohio. Her mother put a doll made by the Italian company Lenci on will call at Halle Brothers, a department store near their home, until she could make the full $11.50 payment. The two named the doll Edith.
戴尔和她的母亲搬到了俄亥俄州克利夫兰。她的母亲在她们家附近的哈勒兄弟百货公司预订了一个由意大利伦奇公司制作的玩偶，直到她能支付全额的11.50美元。两人给那个玩偶取名伊迪丝。
Edie, as Dare's mother was known, was a portrait painter of some renown. Those who sat for her included Winston Churchill, Calvin Coolidge, and Greta Garbo. And in 1924, one of her subjects offered her the use of the penthouse of his Cleveland office building as her studio. For the next 45 years, its 1,500 square feet with a northern exposure skylight would be her home. The same year she moved in, Edie enrolled Dare as a boarding student in a private girls' school.
伊迪丝，也就是戴尔母亲为人所知的名字，是一位享有声誉的肖像画家。她的座上宾包括温斯顿·丘吉尔、卡尔文·柯立芝和葛丽泰·嘉宝。1924年，她的一位模特提议让她使用他位于克利夫兰办公楼顶层作为工作室。在接下来的45年里，那1500平方英尺有着朝北天窗的空间将成为她的家。她搬进去的那一年，伊迪丝让戴尔作为寄宿生进入了一所私立女子学校。
Dare graduated from high school in 1934 and moved to New York to attend drama and art school. She didn't know that her brother, Blaine, was also living in the city. Their uncle orchestrated a reunion in Central Park of the 22-year-old tall, handsome Blaine and the 19-year-old newly-golden Dare. According to one of Dare's cousins, Blaine and Dare fell in love. They even considered concealing their brother and sister relationship in order to marry, an idea they eventually dropped.
戴尔于1934年高中毕业，搬到纽约参加戏剧和艺术学校。她不知道她的哥哥布莱恩也住在城里。他们的叔叔在中央公园安排了一次团聚，对象是22岁高大英俊的布莱恩和19岁刚刚变成金发女郎的戴尔。根据戴尔的一位表亲，布莱恩和戴尔坠入爱河。他们甚至考虑隐瞒兄妹关系以便结婚，后来他们放弃了这个想法。
Dare tried, with little success, to be an actress, and then went on to work as a fashion model, including a stint as the Maidenform bra girl. Soon she switched to the other side of the camera, and her fashion photography began appearing in Vogue, Harper's Bazaar, and Town and Country.
戴尔尝试成为一名演员，但不太成功，后来做了一名时装模特，包括在Maidenform内衣公司做过一阵模特。很快她转到摄像机另一侧，她的时尚摄影作品开始出现在《时尚》、《时尚芭莎》和《城与乡》杂志上。
In the early '40s, Blaine introduced Dare to a British friend of his, named Philip Sandeman, whose family produced port and sherry. Though tall, blond, and dazzlingly beautiful, Dare was strangely childlike, avoidant, and shy, and seemed somehow confused by her powers over men.
40年代初，布莱恩向戴尔介绍了他的英国朋友菲利普·桑德曼，他的家族生产波特酒和雪利酒。虽然高挑、金发且美得令人目眩，戴尔却有一种奇怪的孩童气、回避且害羞，似乎对她对男人的吸引力感到困惑。
Philip was ideal for Dare. Throughout their five year courtship, he remained at a safe distance. First there was the war, and afterward he lived across the ocean. They were engaged, but a week before the wedding, Philip called things off.
菲利普是戴尔的理想人选。在他们五年的求爱过程中，他一直保持着安全的距离。首先是战争，之后他住在海洋彼岸。他们订了婚，但在婚礼前一周，菲利普取消了婚约。
In the years that followed, Dare's close friend, Donald Sewell, said, men always did beat a path to her door. Dare wasn't interested. She never seemed quite of this world, he said. She was ethereal, somehow above normal courtship.
在接下来的几年里，戴尔的好友唐纳德·休厄尔说，男人们总是踏破她的门槛。戴尔对此不感兴趣。她说，她似乎从来不完全属于这个世界。她是超凡脱俗的，不知何故凌驾于正常的求爱之上。
Throughout all of this, Dare seems to have hung onto the dream that Philip would come back to her. Edie no doubt fanned this fantasy. Dare sent Philip's mother photographs of alluring portraits Edie painted of her in this period. In all of them, Dare had posed in low-cut white gowns. Edie also did many portraits of Philip, painting him from Dare's photographs. These were signed by both mother and daughter.
在此期间，戴尔似乎一直坚持着菲利普会回到她身边的梦想。伊迪丝无疑煽动了这个幻想。戴尔给菲利普的母亲寄去了她在此期间拍摄的迷人肖像画照片，照片上全是伊迪丝画的。在所有这些画中，戴尔都穿着低胸的白色礼服。伊迪丝也画了许多菲利普的肖像，根据戴尔的照片绘画。这些画作由母亲和女儿共同签名。
Dare also staged elaborate photographs of herself, seated at her dressing table, a sort of shrine to Philip, with a pencil drawing of him that she had sketched, and a bottle of Sandeman sherry. Clutched in her hands is a letter he had sent to her. She is turned, glancing at the camera wistfully, hopefully. But in 1951, at the age of 30, Philip was killed flying in a demonstration airshow.
戴尔还精心策划了她自己的照片，坐在梳妆台前，某种程度上是菲利普的神龛，放着一张她画的他的铅笔素描，和一瓶桑德曼雪利酒。手里紧紧抓着一封他寄给她的信。她转过身，忧郁而充满希望地看着镜头。但在1951年，30岁那年，菲利普死于一场飞行表演。
After Philip's death, Dare rented her first New York apartment, having lived until then in a series of hotel rooms. She hung her portraits of Philip throughout the apartment, with one by the front door. She made voluminous drapes for the windows and installed smoked glass mirrors. Her all-white boudoir was fitted out with a taffeta canopied princess bed. And next to that, set off by louvered doors, was a dressing room with a vanity table, an oval mirror, and a large closet.
菲利普去世后，戴尔租了她的第一间纽约公寓，此前她一直住在旅馆里。她把菲利普的肖像挂在公寓各处，门口就有一幅。她为窗户做了宽大的帷幔，安装了烟熏玻璃镜。她全白色的闺房配有一张带塔夫绸帷幔的公主床。旁边，由百叶门隔开，是一间更衣室，里面有梳妆台、椭圆形镜子和一个大衣橱。
Dare and her mother were virtually inseparable. Dare made frequent visits to her mother's penthouse in Cleveland. And Edie spent at least one week a month in New York with Dare, sleeping, as was their custom, in the same bed. They seemed to have no idea of the oddness of this arrangement. As Edie told Brooke, I reach over and pat her little bottom in the night.
戴尔和她母亲几乎形影不离。戴尔经常去她在克利夫兰的母亲的顶层公寓。伊迪丝每个月至少在纽约和戴尔待一周，按照她们的习惯，睡在同一张床上。她们似乎对这种安排的奇特毫无察觉。正如伊迪丝告诉布鲁克的，我在夜里伸手拍拍她的小屁股。
Now that Dare had her own apartment, Edie sent along her belongings, including her childhood dolls. After the first, and biggest, trauma of Dare's life, losing her father and brother, consolation had come in the form of Edith, her doll. Now, after the second, losing Philip, Edith was back again.
现在戴尔有了自己的公寓，伊迪丝送来了她的个人物品，包括她童年的玩偶。在戴尔人生中第一次也是最大的创伤——失去父亲和哥哥——之后，慰藉以伊迪丝，她的玩偶的形式到来。现在，在第二次——失去菲利普——之后，伊迪丝又回来了。
Edith was a mess. Her wig was yellowed and tangled, and her clothes were in shreds. Dare quickly set about giving her a completely new look. Long, straight blond hair, usually worn tied up in a high ponytail, and gold hoop earrings. Edith the doll now looked very like Dare herself.
伊迪丝一团糟。她的假发发黄打结，衣服撕成了碎片。戴尔很快着手给她换了一个全新的造型。长而直的金发，通常扎成高高的马尾，戴着金色的圆圈耳环。伊迪丝玩偶现在看起来非常像戴尔本人。
I don't think of Edith as a doll, Dare told an interviewer. She's a personality in her own right. A suitor told me that one day it began with Dare chiding, you didn't say hello to Edith, as though he had rudely neglected to acknowledge a human presence. Another time, when he tried to kiss her, she held the doll out in front of her to block his advances.
我没把伊迪丝看作一个玩偶，戴尔告诉一位采访者。她本身就是一个个性。一位追求者告诉我，有一天戴尔指责他，你没和伊迪丝打招呼，好像他粗鲁地忽略了一个人类的存在。还有一次，当他试图吻她时，她把玩偶举在前面挡住了他的亲昵。
Dare also acquired some teddy bears in this period, after her brother went on a drunken shopping spree with Dorothy Tivis Pollack, a former model, who headed the Figureheads modeling agency where Dare was registered for a time. Blaine was drunk, Dorothy told me, and got weird, as he always did when he drank. We passed FAO Schwarz, and he saw a teddy bear in the window. He decided I had to have one. In we went.
在此期间，戴尔也得到了一些泰迪熊，那是她的哥哥和前模特、曾经负责戴尔注册的Figureheads模特经纪公司的多萝西·提维斯·波拉克进行了一场醉酒购物狂欢后。多萝西告诉我，布莱恩当时喝醉了，变得很古怪，他喝酒时总是这样。我们经过FAO Schwarz，他看到橱窗里有一只泰迪熊。他决定我必须有一只。我们进去了。
But when he saw the bears, he said it would be terrible to buy just one, because the bear would be lonely. With that, he directed the saleswoman to pack up the entire lot, about a dozen stuffed bears. Hundreds of dollars of bears. Since Dare's apartment was just around the corner, we went over there, carrying all these damn teddy bears.
但当他看到这些熊时，他说只买一只太糟糕了，因为那只熊会感到孤独。于是，他指示售货员把整批，大约十几只毛绒熊都包起来。价值几百美元的熊。因为戴尔的公寓就在拐角处，我们带着所有这些该死的泰迪熊去了那里。
Within minutes of their arrival, Dorothy recalled, Blaine and Dare were seated on the floor, surrounded by bears, telling bear stories in various bear voices. Soon Dare added Edith, the doll, to the party.
到达后几分钟，多萝西回忆道，布莱恩和戴尔坐在地板上，被熊群包围着，用各种熊的声音讲熊的故事。很快戴尔把伊迪丝，那个玩偶，也加到了聚会中。
Edith, Dare later told an interviewer, looked so happy with the bears that she decided to photograph them all together. Soon, she was making them into a book. She thought up a storyline, made Edith outfits, and photographed her doll and bears in her apartment and around New York. In all her poses, Edith appears to be an animated, thinking, feeling little girl.
戴尔后来告诉采访者，伊迪丝和熊在一起看起来很开心，所以她决定把它们聚在一起拍照。很快，她就把它们做成了一本书。她想出了一个故事情节，给伊迪丝做了衣服，并在她的公寓和纽约各地拍摄她的玩偶和熊。在所有的摆拍中，伊迪丝看起来就像一个生动、有思想、有感情的小女孩。
The story of the lonely doll was, in some measure, Dare's own story. The book and her life share the same set of themes. Seeking love and approval, fearing abandonment, risking separation and autonomy. In other words, the issues inherent in growing up. But in the book, she found a way to make it right, removing a mother from the proceedings, and providing her alter ego, Edith, with love and rescue in the form of two mail teddy bears.
《孤独的玩偶》的故事在某种程度上也是戴尔自己的故事。这本书和她的生活有着相同的主题。寻求爱和认可，害怕被遗弃，冒险分离和自主。换句话说，成长中固有的问题。但在书中，她找到了一种让事情变好的方法，从情节中移除了一位母亲，并以两只邮来的泰迪熊的形式为她的化身伊迪丝提供了爱和拯救。
With the publication of The Lonely Doll, and the 18 books that followed, came recognition that Dare had never experienced, and with which she seemed highly uncomfortable. She would have been 43 in 1957, the year the book was published. 48 when she gave her age as 35 to the Saturday Evening Post.
随着《孤独的玩偶》及其随后18本书的出版，带来了戴尔从未经历过的认可，而她似乎对这种认可感到极度不适。1957年，即该书出版那年，她本该43岁。当她向《周六晚邮报》谎报年龄为35岁时，她已经48岁了。
Her mother, Edie, however, was completely at home with all the attention. The two became a sort of team, with Edie in the assistant's role. They adored traveling, and built it into the story lines of Dare's books, the most elaborate one being Lona: A Fairy Tale. For this, they traveled throughout Europe, scouting out scenery for the story of a princess who must overcome the spell of an evil wizard who has changed her into a tiny doll. Dare herself posed as the princess in her full-size incarnation. She would set up the shot, focus the camera, don her gown, and have her mother trip the shutter.
然而，她的母亲伊迪丝对所有的关注感到完全自在。两人成了某种团队，伊迪丝担任助理角色。她们热爱旅行，并将其融入戴尔书中的情节，最复杂的一本是《洛娜：一个童话故事》。为此，她们游遍了欧洲，为这个故事 scouting 场景，讲述了一位公主必须克服一个邪恶巫师的咒语，因为他把她变成了一个微小的玩偶。戴尔本人在她的全尺寸化身中扮演公主。她会设置拍摄点，对焦相机，穿上礼服，让她的母亲按下快门。
A version of Jean Nathan's story first appeared in the literary journal Tin House. She's working on a book about Dare Wright to be published by Random House.
简·内森文章的一个版本首次出现在文学杂志《锡屋》上。她正在写一本关于戴尔·赖特的书，将由兰登书屋出版。
Coming up, girl turns helicopter into baby and other true stories, in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，女孩把直升机变成婴儿以及其他真实故事，一分钟后，来自国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, dolls.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同类型的故事。今天的节目，玩偶。
Most important, from the beginning, they are characters to be nurtured. Hugging it, feeling it against your cheek, rocking it, just having it. It's a bulwark against loneliness.
最重要的是，从一开始，它们就是需要被培育的角色。拥抱它，感受它贴着你的脸颊，摇晃它，仅仅拥有它。这是对抗孤独的堡垒。
Vivian Paley was a kindergarten teacher for decades, won the MacArthur Genius Grant for her many books about the stories that children invent, and the way they play, and what it's about. She says, children use dolls and they make up stories for similar reason, to act out moments and feelings that are knocking around in their heads. In her classroom, Vivian Paley would have her students invent stories and then act them out. And she says, there's one idea that comes up in small children's stories more than any other.
薇薇安·佩利做了几十年的幼儿园老师，因其关于孩子们发明的各种故事及其玩耍方式以及这其中意义的书籍而获得了麦克阿瑟天才奖。她说，孩子们使用玩偶并编造故事是因为类似的原因，为了演绎那些在他们脑海中碰撞的时刻和感受。在她的课堂上，薇薇安·佩利会让学生们发明故事并演出来。她说，有一个想法在幼儿故事中出现的频率比任何其他想法都高。
So many of the stories that young children tell have to do with an animal or a little girl or boy being lonely, and walking in the woods, and finding someone to play with. It is the universal, most successful story. And if you have a kindergarten class, or a preschool class, or a first grade class, and-- although this would never happen-- but let's say, all 24 children told this story.
幼儿讲述的许多故事都与一只动物或一个小女孩或小男孩感到孤独，在森林里走，并找到可以一起玩的人有关。这是普遍的、最成功的故事。如果你有一个幼儿园班级，或者一个学前班，或者一年级班级，并且——虽然这种情况永远不会发生——但假设，所有24个孩子都讲了这个故事。
There was a lonely deer. He had no one to play with. And then a cougar came up and said, I'll be your friend. Next story. There was a lonely boy. He had no one to play with. And on and on.
有一只孤独的鹿。他没有人和他一起玩。然后一只美洲狮走过来说，我会做你的朋友。下一个故事。有一个孤独的男孩。他没有人和他一起玩。如此循环往复。
Not one child in the class would say, what, again? Haven't we had enough of that already? No. They would say, more. More. Tell us again that when you're lonely, someone's going to come up and say, I'll play with you.
班上没有一个孩子会说，什么，又是这个？我们还没听够吗？不。他们会说，更多。更多。再告诉我们一次，当你孤独时，会有人过来对你说，我会和你一起玩。
Vivian Paley says that it's by making up stories together that small children become friends. In one of her books, she tells the story of one of the children in her classroom who used a doll and a story to isolate himself from other students, and how it was through other stories and dolls that other children finally pulled him out of his isolation.
薇薇安·佩利说，正是通过一起编造故事，幼儿才能成为朋友。在她的一本书中，她讲述了班上的一个孩子如何使用玩偶和一个故事将自己与同学隔离开来，以及正是通过其他故事和玩偶，其他孩子最终将他从孤立中拉了出来。
The doll in this case was a toy helicopter. Vivian now tells the story with actors recreating scenes from her classroom from transcriptions of what really occurred.
在这个例子中，玩偶是一个玩具直升机。薇薇安现在用演员重现她课堂上的场景，这些场景来自实际发生情况的记录。
Every day in the corner of the classroom, nestled between the black cabinet and the bay window bench, Jason arranges big wooden blocks into walls and crouches behind them. He calls this his airport. The walls surround him, high enough so he can barely be seen over the top.
每天在教室的角落里，依偎在黑色柜子和飘窗长椅之间，杰森把大木块排列成墙，蹲在墙后面。他称这为他的机场。墙壁包围着他，高到他几乎从上面看不见。
This blade is turning around. Now you're going faster. Now you're going faster. Now you're going to crash. Now you're going off the ground. And now you're going up, up, up. Now you're going loud. Brrrrm. Now you're going to land. OK. All safely.
这个桨叶在转动。现在你转得更快了。现在你转得更快了。现在你要坠毁了。现在你要离开地面了。现在你要上升，上升，上升了。现在你要发出巨大的声音了。呜呜呜。现在你要着陆了。好了。一切安全。
Jason plays alone. He tells stories to himself. He seems unaware of our habits and customs. He wails in fright if his helicopter is touched, and he breaks up our talk with ear-splitting noises.
杰森独自玩耍。他对自己讲故事。他似乎不知道我们的习惯和习俗。如果他的直升机被触碰，他会发出恐惧的哀号，并用刺耳的噪音打破我们的谈话。
[MAKING NOISES]
[发出噪音]
His helicopter story isolates him. If you ask him a question, he says his helicopter is broken. If you suggest an activity, he rushes away to fix his helicopter. He hasn't learned to listen to anyone else's story, and stories are the way children get to know each other.
他的直升机故事使他与世隔绝。如果你问他一个问题，他说他的直升机坏了。如果你建议一项活动，他会冲去修理他的直升机。他还没学会倾听别人的故事，而故事是孩子们互相了解的方式。
[MAKING NOISES]
[发出噪音]
Pretend a bad alligator peeked downstairs.
假装一只坏鳄鱼偷看了楼下。
Yeah, and then we hiss him. Then we fighted him.
是啊，然后我们嘘他。然后我们和他打了一架。
But who's the alligator? Hey, Jason. You're the alligator. OK, Jason?
但谁是鳄鱼？嘿，杰森。你是鳄鱼。好吗，杰森？
Up, up, up. Down, down, down. Oh, we're going to crash.
上升，上升，上升。下降，下降，下降。哦，我们要坠毁了。
Children usually take part in each other's stories because they need friends and they want to be part of a drama. If Jason would agree to be the alligator, Joseph and Simon would later tell their families, Jason is my friend. It's that easy when it works.
孩子们通常会参与彼此的故事，因为他们需要朋友，想要成为戏剧的一部分。如果杰森同意做鳄鱼，约瑟夫和西蒙以后会告诉他们的家人，杰森是我的朋友。当它起作用时，一切就是这么简单。
Jason, look at me. You want to be an alligator or not?
杰森，看着我。你想做鳄鱼还是不想？
This is a rescue helicopter. Someone broke it. I have to fix the blades.
这是一架救援直升机。有人弄坏了它。我必须修理桨叶。
I got an idea, Jason. Your helicopter has to rescue us, OK? Help, help. A monster alligator in the dark. Save me, helicopter. To the rescue. Save the day.
我有办法了，杰森。你的直升机必须救援我们，好吗？救命，救命。黑暗中有一只怪兽鳄鱼。救救我，直升机。来救援吧。拯救这一天。
Jason is silent, bent over his helicopter. Joseph glares at him. His best logic isn't working, and he's puzzled.
杰森沉默了，弯腰盯着他的直升机。约瑟夫瞪着他。他最好的逻辑不起作用，他感到困惑。
I heard Joseph call for help, Jason. Can your helicopter save the snakes?
我听见约瑟夫呼救了，杰森。你的直升机能救那些蛇吗？
My blade is broken. Someone broke this blade.
我的桨叶坏了。有人弄坏了这个桨叶。
Can you show Joseph and Simon how you fix it?
你能给约瑟夫和西蒙展示一下你是怎么修理它的吗？
I can't show someone how you fix it.
我不能给别人看你是怎么修理它的。
He calls the children someone. After two months, he refers to no one but me by name. He enters the classroom feeling different, frightened, attacked, that he must defend himself. But every child knows these feelings, in one way or another.
他称孩子们为“别人”。两个月后，除了我，他指代任何人都不称呼名字。他走进教室时感到与众不同，感到害怕，感到被攻击，他必须保护自己。但每个孩子以这样或那样的方式都知道这些感觉。
Every day, after I've collected 10 or 12 stories, we act the stories out. I read each story out loud, and the children take different roles. The stage where we do this is a taped square in the center of the story room rug. It is sacrosanct when stories are performed. The children learn to keep off the stage unless they are in the story.
每天，在我收集了10到12个故事后，我们把故事演出来。我大声读出每个故事，孩子们扮演不同的角色。我们进行表演的舞台是故事室地毯中央的一个用胶带粘出的方块。当故事被表演时，这里是神圣不可侵犯的。孩子们学会了除非是在故事中，否则不要踏上舞台。
Jason refuses to follow the rule, and it upsets every one. His motor tunes up as each story begins, and within a sentence or two he is flying around the stage. He does this as we act out Simon's story.
杰森拒绝遵守规则，这让每个人都很不安。随着每个故事的开始，他的引擎就开始轰鸣，一两句话之内，他就在舞台上飞来飞去了。当我们在表演西蒙的故事时，他做了同样的事情。
[MAKING  NOISES]
[发出噪音]
Simon, is there a helicopter in this story?
西蒙，这个故事里有直升机吗？
No.
没有。
Then you mustn't come on stage, Jason.
那么你不可以上台，杰森。
Jason has heard this reasoning before. I ask this question all the time when he forges on stage. Is there a helicopter in this story? The answer is always no.
杰森以前听过这种推理。每当他冲上舞台时，我总是问这个问题。这个故事里有直升机吗？答案总是没有。
Simon, is there a helicopter in your story? Do the squirrels see a helicopter?
西蒙，你的故事里有直升机吗？松鼠们看到直升机了吗？
No. Yeah. They do. They heard it flying over there, then it lands, on this spot, right here.
没有。啊。它们看到了。它们听见它在那边飞，然后它着陆了，就在这个位置，就在这儿。
[MAKING NOISES] I turn off the motor.
[发出噪音] 我关掉了引擎。
Jason stops, just where Simon pointed. He has deliberately furthered another child's story. Today, Jason has listened.
杰森停了下来，就在西蒙指的地方。他特意推动了另一个孩子的故事。今天，杰森听进去了。
The next day, I tell Jason, you turned off your motor when Simon told you to land. Now you know all about stories. Do you want to tell one? He says yes, and launches right in.
第二天，我对杰森说，当西蒙让你着陆时，你关掉了你的引擎。现在你很了解故事了。你想讲一个吗？他说好，并且直接开始了。
And a helicopter, a turbo prop. It's flying.
还有一架直升机，一个涡轮螺旋桨。它在飞。
How could his first story be anything else? In the story room, Jason zooms around the rug as I read his story. He continues to fly several moments after I'm done reading.
他的第一个故事怎么可能是别的呢？在故事室里，当我读他的故事时，杰森在地毯周围嗖嗖地飞。在我读完后，他继续飞了几分钟。
I wonder if the helicopter sees another plane?
我想知道直升机有没有看到另一架飞机？
Someone.
别人。
Which someone?
哪个别人？
Squirrel someone.
松鼠别人。
He means me. I'm the plane, right?
他是指我。我是飞机，对吧？
Jason nods, and the two aircraft zoom around the room. Chins forward, arms in motion, the two boys fly together in formation.
杰森点了点头，两架飞机在房间周围嗖嗖地飞。下巴向前，手臂在运动，两个男孩结队飞行。
Young children see themselves always inside a story. A young child will spend easily 3/4 of his time in fantasy play. It's through stories and fantasies that children understand the world. It is their intuitive approach to all occasions. It is the way they think.
幼儿总是把自己看作故事的一部分。幼儿很容易花3/4的时间进行幻想游戏。正是通过故事和幻想，孩子们了解世界。这是他们对所有场合的直觉方法。这就是他们的思考方式。
Jason still plays alone.
杰森仍然独自玩耍。
I want to. I always have to be a helicopter. But you always tell me not to.
我想这样做。我总是必须是一架直升机。但你总是告诉我不要。
I didn't tell you not to be a helicopter, Jason. But Simon asked you to come into his squirrelly hole. And I thought you didn't hear him since you didn't answer.
杰森，我没让你不要做直升机。但西蒙请你进入他的松鼠洞。我想你没听见他，因为你没回答。
Because that squirrelly guy is outside the window.
因为那个松鼠家伙在窗外。
I'm not outside. Don't say that.
我不在外面。别那样说。
Jason seems surprised that he's gotten such an intense response.
杰森似乎对自己得到了如此强烈的回应感到惊讶。
That squirrel someone is outside.
那个松鼠别人在外面。
I hate you, Jason. You're never my friend.
我讨厌你，杰森。你永远不是我的朋友。
Jason still doesn't play with the other children. But one day, he points at Simon.
杰森仍然不和其他孩子玩。但有一天，他指着西蒙。
Someone's hiding in my airport.
有人藏在我的机场里。
No. I'm not in there.
不。我没在里面。
Simon is in my airport.
西蒙在我的机场里。
You're lying, you doody head.
你在撒谎，你个笨蛋。
Simon is in my airport.
西蒙在我的机场里。
Don't say my name. Tell him not to, teacher.
别叫我的名字。告诉他不要，老师。
Jason, Simon doesn't want you to pretend he's in your airport. Do you really want him to come in? Really come in?
杰森，西蒙不希望你假装他在你的机场里。你真的希望他进来吗？真的进来吗？
No.
不。
Jason, can I help you find someone to play inside your airport? Teachers do that, you know. Once I helped Simon find a mother squirrel. Remember, Simon?
杰森，我能帮你找个人在你的机场里玩吗？老师会做那种事，你知道的。曾经我帮西蒙找过一只松鼠妈妈。记得吗，西蒙？
I don't want a mother squirrel.
我不要松鼠妈妈。
Who do you want?
你想要谁？
Someone hiding in my airport.
有人藏在我的机场里。
OK. Listen everyone. Jason needs someone to hide in his airport. Who will do that?
好的。听着大家。杰森需要有人藏在他的机场里。谁愿意那样做？
Only if I can be the mother.
除非我能当妈妈。
It's a helicopter house.
这是一个直升机房子。
I'll be the mother, and you be the baby.
我当妈妈，你当宝宝。
No.
不。
I'm She-Ra and you're the helicopter?
我是希瑞，你是直升机？
Yes.
是的。
Samantha climbs behind the wall of blocks gingerly, and sits down next to Jason.
萨曼莎小心翼翼地爬到积木墙后，坐在杰森旁边。
My blades are broken. I'm fixing them.
我的桨叶坏了。我在修理它们。
We have to make beds. I'll get the pillows. Save my place.
我们必须铺床。我去拿枕头。给我留个位置。
Jason covers Samantha's place with one hand, and blows on the helicopter blades.
杰森用一只手盖住萨曼莎的位置，并对着直升机桨叶吹气。
[BLOWS] Turn around. Turn around. Ooh, not such a good spinning. Kick the house down. Kick the house down.
[吹气] 转动。转动。噢，旋转得不太好。把房子踢倒。把房子踢倒。
Lie down, little helicopter.
躺下，小直升机。
She has pillows and sheets, and she makes Jason into a baby as delicately as she can.
她有枕头和被子，她尽可能细腻地把杰森变成了一个婴儿。
Kick the house down.
把房子踢倒。
Shh, little helicopter.
嘘，小直升机。
With this one episode, Samantha launches a wholehearted pursuit of Jason that, more than any other event in the school year, brings him out of the helicopter house, and into the social life of the classroom. She is determined to make Jason into her baby, however he may object.
通过这一个小插曲，萨曼莎启动了对杰森的全心全意的追求，这比学年中任何其他事件都更能让他走出直升机房子，进入教室的社交生活。她决心要把杰森变成她的婴儿，无论他如何反抗。
Other times, Jason shows he's unable to join the other children's fantasy play. When he wanders into a game the boys are playing, he doesn't understand what they're doing, and everyone yells at him to get out.
其他时候，杰森显示出他无法加入其他孩子的幻想游戏。当他漫无目的地走进男孩们正在玩的游戏时，他不明白他们在做什么，大家都会大声叫他滚开。
Don't go there, Jason. You're breaking up the marshway.
别去那儿，杰森。你打断了沼泽路。
You're breaking up the marshway.
你打断了沼泽路。
Get out, Jason.
滚开，杰森。
Don't. It's the marshway.
别。这是沼泽路。
I'm going there now because-- because-- there isn't a--
我现在要去那儿，因为——因为——没有一个——
No, Jason. You don't even know what school is.
不，杰森。你甚至不知道学校是什么。
Jason starts to cry. This is also a very emotional moment for me. Alex is right. Jason has interrupted play in an illogical way, in a way that shows he doesn't know that a story is going on. And Alex knows enough to say, you don't know what school is.
杰森开始哭了。这对我来说也是一个非常情绪化的时刻。亚历克斯是对的。杰森以不合逻辑的方式打断了游戏，以一种表明他不知道故事正在进行的方式。亚历克斯知道足以说，你不知道学校是什么。
Which is to say, you don't know what story is. You don't know what fantasy is. You don't know what the most logical relationship between human beings is. Because stories work by the most basic logic, logic a child can understand. It is not too much to say that the only time a child understands everything is in a story.
也就是，你不知道故事是什么。你不知道幻想是什么。你不知道人类之间最合乎逻辑的关系是什么。因为故事是以最基本的逻辑工作的，孩子能理解的逻辑。说一个孩子唯一一次理解所有事情就是在故事中，这并不为过。
As the weeks pass, Samantha's pursuit of Jason grows more inventive.
随着几周过去，萨曼莎对杰森的追求变得更加有创意。
I'm putting you in my story, Jason. Come here and listen.
我把你放进我的故事里了，杰森。过来听着。
I don't want to.
我不想。
Yes, you have to. Or I won't give you a piece of gum when my daddy buys some.
是的，你必须听。否则我爸爸买口香糖时，我不给你一块。
Jason sits down next to Samantha and watches as she dictates her story. If a teacher had threatened him in that way, he would have withdrawn. When Samantha threatens him, his interest in Samantha's story is heightened. He correctly interprets her warning as a sign of friendship, and the story proves him correct.
杰森坐在萨曼莎旁边，看着她口述她的故事。如果一位老师那样威胁他，他会退缩。当萨曼莎威胁他时，他对萨曼莎故事的兴趣提高了。他正确地将她的警告解读为友谊的标志，而故事证明他是对的。
Once upon a time, there was a little girl. Then a helicopter came. Then the little girl said hello to the helicopter. Then a kitty says hello to the helicopter. Then the kitty, and the girl, and the helicopter are friends.
从前，有一个小女孩。然后一架直升机来了。然后小女孩对直升机说你好。然后一只小猫对直升机说你好。然后小猫、女孩和直升机成了朋友。
After she's done, Jason gathers up a pile of papers for his helicopter drawings.
她讲完后，杰森收集了一叠纸用来画他的直升机。
Don't draw now, Jason. You want to be my husband?
现在别画了，杰森。你想做我的丈夫吗？
No, because I'm busy.
不想，因为我很忙。
Or the baby, or the cook? Do you want to make a birthday cake? Do you want to be dead, but then you come alive? Remember, you liked it that time?
或者是宝宝，还是厨师？你想做一个生日蛋糕吗？你想死一次，然后又复活吗？记得吗，你上次很喜欢那样？
As Samantha imagines other scenes, she doesn't notice that Jason has stopped drawing, and instead, has cut out a large oval shape.
当萨曼莎想象其他场景时，她没注意到杰森已经停止了绘画，相反，他剪出了一个大的椭圆形。
This is your cape, Samantha. Be a queen. I'm the king.
这是你的斗篷，萨曼莎。做个女王。我是国王。
But when I glance at their block castle a while later, Jason seems to be the queen's baby. Does Samantha continue to push Jason into the baby role because he appears babyish to her? I doubt it. I've seen too many mature children prefer the baby crib in play. Samantha's motives, I think, are simple and understandable. She likes being the mother and she's fond of Jason. To express her true feelings, she must act the role of his mother. The mother-baby or father-baby relationship spells love most dramatically for many children. By year's end, Samantha will have moved to the big sister-little sister version of the same emotion.
但当我过一会儿看向他们的积木城堡时，杰森似乎成了女王的宝宝。萨曼莎继续把杰森推向宝宝角色是因为她在她看来杰森像婴儿吗？我对此表示怀疑。我见过太多成熟的孩子更喜欢在玩耍时选择婴儿床。我认为萨曼莎的动机很简单且可以理解。她喜欢当妈妈，而且她很喜欢杰森。为了表达她真实的感情，她必须扮演他妈妈的角色。母婴或父婴关系为许多孩子最戏剧性地表达了爱。到年底，萨曼莎会将同一种情绪演变成大姐-小妹的版本。
No, you dope. You [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
不，你个笨蛋。你 [不清晰]
Once changes begin, they happen fast. In one week in April, Jason is a she-baby airplane on Monday, a smaller person looking for Easter eggs on Tuesday, a morning and night boy on Wednesday, an angry fighting person on Thursday. And on Friday, he finds a remarkable new role for his helicopter that takes my breath away in admiration and wonder.
一旦变化开始，它们发生得很快。四月的一周里，杰森在周一是一个婴儿飞机，周二是一个寻找复活节彩蛋的更小的人，周三是一个晨昏男孩，周四是一个愤怒的战斗者。周五，他为他的直升机找到了一个非凡的新角色，令我感到钦佩和惊叹。
Do you want to play, Jason?
杰森，你想玩吗？
Yes. You sit there. I made a two seater. Wait. A three seater. One more seat it needs.
是的。你坐在那儿。我做了个双座。等等。三座。还需要一个座位。
Why?
为什么？
Because I'm going to pick up someone at school, because not anyone will come to pick them up and walk them home.
因为我要在学校接一个人，因为没别人会来接他们并送他们回家。
Jason is letting someone else into the helicopter. And when his helicopter finally emerges from its house, he gives it a single task. To take a mother and her child home after school. Underlying this fantasy is a basic fear. No one has arrived to take the school child home. The child is lost at school.
杰森让别人进入了直升机。当他的直升机最终从房子里出来时，他给了它一个任务。在放学后把妈妈和她的孩子带回家。在这个幻想背后是一种基本的恐惧。没有人来接那个学生回家。那个孩子在学校走丢了。
I'm going to pick up someone at school. Because not anyone will come to pick them up and walk them home. They're going to hold everyone's hand. One kid's going to hold the other kid's hand.
我要在学校接一个人。因为没别人会来接他们并送他们回家。他们要牵着每个人的手。一个孩子要牵着另一个孩子的手。
And I'm the mom, OK?
我当妈妈，好吗？
Yes. And everyone, when I get out of school, I'm going to pick them up in my airplane.
是的。每个人，当我从学校出来，我要用我的飞机接他们。
I'll be the kid, Jason. OK?
我当那个孩子，杰森。好吗？
Yes, you're the kid. Hold your mom's hand. I'm flying you home.
是的，你是那个孩子。牵着你妈妈的手。我送你们回家。
Well, Vivian Paley's book, The Boy Who Would Be a Helicopter, from which this was adapted, is published by Harvard University Press. The children's dialogue was reenacted from classroom transcripts by Joe Robinson, Jason [? Bogart, ?] [? Aisha ?] [? Harmon, ?] [? Matt ?] [? Kady, ?] Anna [? Klumsky ?] Beth [? Iams, ?] and Jenny [? Banachefski, ?] who played Jason. Funding came from the University of Chicago's William Benton Broadcast Project, Claudia [? Daily, ?] and the late Louis Friedman, supervising producers.
嗯，薇薇安·佩利的《想成为直升机的男孩》一书，从中改编了这一节，由哈佛大学出版社出版。儿童对话由乔·罗宾逊、杰森 [?博加特?]、[?艾莎?] [?哈蒙?]、[?马特?] [?卡迪?]、安娜 [?克鲁姆斯基?]、贝丝 [?伊姆斯?] 和饰演杰森的詹妮 [?巴纳切夫斯基?] 根据课堂记录重现。资金来自芝加哥大学的威廉·本顿广播项目、克劳迪娅 [?戴利?] 和已故的刘易斯·弗里德曼，监制制作人。
Our program was produced today by Susan Burton and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Blue Chevigny, and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and conciliary Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Eric [? Harverston. ?] Musical help from Mr. John Connors.
我们的节目今天由苏珊·伯顿和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、布鲁·切维尼和朱莉·斯奈德。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自托德·巴赫曼和埃里克 [?哈弗斯顿?]。音乐帮助来自约翰·康纳斯先生。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you know, you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website at www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. This week a photo on there of Dare Wright. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如需购买本节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。或者你知道，你可以免费在网上收听我们大部分节目，网址是www.thislife.org。感谢运行该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。本周上面有戴尔·赖特的照片。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING  CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who can be found every morning in his office--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他每天早晨都可以在他的办公室里被找到——
Seated on the floor, surrounded by bears, telling bear stories in various bear voices.
坐在地板上，被熊群包围着，用各种熊的声音讲熊的故事。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》的更多故事中。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。